all right if you want to see some of the
best drifting you've ever seen on screen
with no cgi
this movie you need to watch
[Music]
what's up guys it's me bobby we're
talking about a live drift now you might
know the name of this movie by alive
hoon that's what it was called in japan
and of course when they distributed
outside of japan they decided to change
the name to make it more universal but
if you go on google or any search engine
out there search a live hoon h-o-o-n
and that is what you'll find more
information on this movie about and this
is really a drifter's paradise in terms
of cinema i mean you've got the drift
kings of japan in this they were
consulting they're driving in this and
there is zero cg in this film they're
very proud to call this a zero cg film
everything is done what you see on the
driving how close they're drifting
around the track
everything is real a lot of gopros were
damaged in this and we you know and
you're watching the film and there's a
big change from gopro action camera
footage to cinema quality footage okay
now i hear they're improving that when
they distribute it out to the other
countries out there but the copy of the
movie i saw it was like gopro hero4 and
then 4k and then hero4 then 4k it's a
little bit jarring
but you forgive it when you see the
action because you're seeing nissan
sylvia you're seeing your toyota supras
and you're seeing the best of the best
and drifting out there in japan and it
will blow your mind if you watch tokyo
drift from fast and furious right you
thought that was cool you ain't
seen nothing yet until you watch this
movie okay now the storyline of this
film is interesting um
you kind of get i mean after the first
15 20 minutes you kind of know how the
movie's going to play out but it's
interesting to see nonetheless basically
the story is about this uh this gamer
his name is kochi oba uh he's one of
japan's top gran turismo players and
this drifting team that's uh they have
one of the best drifting uh
drivers
in the country unfortunately got into an
accident they can't continue so they
need to find a replacement driver in the
meantime
and so they go on to finding another
driver but they don't have a lot of
money so the daughter of this legendary
driver decides why don't we just try to
find someone who's really good at gaming
because they can do well in gran turismo
or a driving sport maybe they can do
well in this so she searches out kochi
she uh gives him a chance to try it out
he's never driven a car before he gets
behind the wheel and then all of a
sudden he thinks about it his gran
turismo and by the way gran turismo it's
like i was like his playstation sponsor
this movie because it's in there quite
prominently now he has to learn a little
bit more of the ways of driving a car
but the fundamentals are there now
what's funny about this film right
is they have the stereotypical gamer
kochi is this kid young boy good looking
boy by the way head down all the time
barely looks up
this guy might say
20 words the entire movie maybe he
barely talks
i mean the girl
cute charismatic
she likes him she finds him a bit
attractive i don't know why he doesn't
talk but
i thought i thought it he had like some
sort of
mental condition i was like oh man
really they're like no no that's just
his character i'm like because he
doesn't change throughout the entire
movie he's the same way like even if he
grows with the team
i'm like oh man dude please talk you got
a girl that likes you man come on
get to it no doesn't happen not at least
but that's sort of okay if you guys
watch some asian cinema that's sometimes
how the young boys are portrayed like
that and the women are the more dominant
more vocal more outgoing it's i don't
know it is what it is nonetheless uh
they bring him onto the team he starts
learning his ways he starts becoming a
really good driver he does a practice
round with one of the top drifting
drivers in japan he actually holds his
own and so you kind of know how this is
going to play out throughout the film in
terms of acting performances this is an
academy awards here okay guys this is
just one of the mill fun
uh it's almost like a tv movie in a lot
of ways right but it's got the drifting
aspect which makes it unique but it is a
fun movie to watch and you're going to
have uh you know you're going to have
some chuckles with the bad guys they
really played up they really ham enough
to be the bad guys out there the bad
drivers and the good guys as well um but
it you're there for the drifting and i
think singapore is the first market if
i'm not mistaken that's gonna be seen
this movie outside of japan we did see
an advanced screening of it and it was
fun to watch it really was i mean the
drifting blew my mind at actually how
good it is so if you're in the cars like
that you love that scene you're going to
really appreciate what they have done
with this but if you're looking for a
really solid storyline
i mean come on guys
i'll put it this way it's as good as
some of the more recent fast and the
furious films okay
it's that in that era but the drifting
supersedes fast and furious anyway those
are my thoughts on a live drift let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below follow us on facebook
subscribe to the channel we got a lot
more videos to check out right here so
enjoy those we'll see you soon
[Music]
you